My name is Akhilan
Boopathy, and my major
is in electrical engineering
and computer science.
My project is on robustness
of neural networks.
Neural networks have
become increasingly
popular for a variety
of tasks, most notably
for image classification.
Unfortunately,
they're susceptible
to adversarial attacks.
This is when the input
to a neural network
is slightly perturbed in order
to cause a misclassification.
This has serious
implications in applications
like self-driving cars, for
instance, where adversaries
could cause accidents.
Fortunately, we can find
regions in the input
space that are certified to
be robust to perturbations.
So for example, in this image,
this ostrich, if perturbed,
will still be
classified as an ostrich
within these green regions.
This raises the
question, how do we
efficiently train
neural networks to have
these large regions of
certified robustness?
Our approach is
to use two margins
to quantify the uncertainties
in the network at each layer.
One margin tracks a level
of linear uncertainty,
while another margin tracks
a level of nonlinearity.
These two margins
can then be used
to approximate an upper bound
on the worst-case performance
of the network or the
worst-case adversarial loss.
Here, we show our
current results.
On the y-axis, we have
certified accuracies,
which are essentially
the fraction of points
in a test set that
we can show or prove
to be robust to adversaries
of a certain size.
On the x-axis, we show the
assumed adversarial attack
size.
The red dotted lines show
the current state-of-the-art
certified robust
training method,
while the blue solid
line shows our method.
As illustrated, for
large perturbation sizes,
we can achieve higher
certified accuracy bounds
compared to the current
state of the art.
In addition, our method only
takes three times the training
time of conventional
training, which
is on par with the
current state of art
in terms of training time.
Next, we hope to scale this
method to larger networks
and larger data sets.